[Music]
tonight on Brian Ross investigates what
robert muller failed to fully
investigate in his russia probe big part
of their effort was designed to suppress
african-american voter turnout how the
russians produced these attacks on
Hillary Clinton this woman is a witch
you know he's tried to pretend like an
angel but she's a new food to her how
fake Russian Facebook posts urged
african-american voters to vote from
home by text something not possible to
do when you look at the black vote in
Philadelphia in Detroit and in Milwaukee
it wasn't what it was in 2012 the
precise same tactics Trump campaign
German Paul Manafort put in place just a
coincidence some kinds of coordination
could have been taking place Plus
showdown with Iran a British ship seized
alleged CIA spies captured back and
forth cyberattacks is a quiet war
already underway Iran has to be very
very careful and our shoutout for the
South Carolina reporter whose stories
helped send a top prosecutor to jail for
using public money to go on vacation and
led to investigations of powerful County
Sherriff's for corruption and covering
up their misdeeds time and time again
we're finding that politics and law
enforcement don't mix from the law and
crime Network studios in New York City's
Herald Square this is Brian Ross
investigates
good evening and welcome tonight what
you did not hear about during the
testimony a former Special Counsel
Robert bowler before Congress the facts
of how the Russians targeted
african-american voters in an effort to
keep them from going to the polls a
strategy that almost exactly paralleled
that of the Trump campaign during the
last election political pros call it
voter suppression so how was it that a
group of Russians in an office building
in st. Petersburg were able to precisely
target the same voters that Republicans
were targeting here just a coincidence
the misinformation effort on the part of
Russian trolls this morning we're
learning Russian interference went
beyond the election the Russian set up
30 Facebook pages targeting African
Americans there's been all this talk
from the malla report to the Senate and
House investigatory committees about the
fact of Russian interference in the 2016
presidential election what there hasn't
been is an examination on how they
sought to interfere in our elections
Marc Morial a former mayor of New
Orleans
now runs the National Urban League it
appears as though a big part of their
effort was designed to suppress African
American voter turnout all she wants is
followed by for example creating trolls
and memes and fake personalities who
were associated in a line with the black
lives matter movement and use those if
you will mouthpieces
to suggest that African Americans should
not vote this woman is a witch you know
he's tried to pretend like an angel but
she's I knew who they created if you
will
Amin a social media meme under the
banner of African Americans for Hillary
Clinton as though it was coming from a
group of African Americans who supported
Hillary Clinton and her photo on it what
it said is avoid the lines vote from
home text to this number of course there
was no way to vote from home or to vote
via text now people would say well who
would be so gullible
consider an 18 19 21 year old person
who's grown up in the social media were
who all of a sudden sees something
coming quote-unquote from the campaign
suggesting that they could vote from
home and that all came from Russia from
an operation called of the internet
research agency in st. Petersburg with
what US officials say was surprising
sophistication in this deception
according to the Pew Research Center
turnout among African American voters
was down substantially in the 2016
election from 66 percent of eligible
voters to 60 percent of eligible voters
a decrease of 765,000 nationwide we had
such a close election that if the
Russians succeeded in simply fooling
some of the people some of the time in
only some of the states they could have
affected this election I wonder who in
the United States may have been
cooperating with them or assisting them
or aiding them or betting them I can't
answer that question what answer comes
from what happened on the top floor of
this building in New York City at a
private cigar club where according to
the Muller report it was here that Trump
campaign Chairman Paul Manafort quote
brief kolob Nick identified by the FBI
as a Russian operative on the state of
the Trump campaign and mana forts plan
to win the election that briefing
encompassed the campaign's messaging and
its internal polling data here is former
Special Counsel Muller confirmed all of
that and more in his congressional
testimony this week months before that
meeting mana Ford had caused internal
data to be shared with kulhanek and the
sharing continued for some period of
time after their August meeting isn't
that correct accurate it also included a
discussion of battleground states which
men are identified as Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and Minnesota isn't that
correct that's great who knows what was
going on with the president but at least
at the the metaphor level I think
there's very strong evidence if not yet
a smoking gun that some kinds of
nation could have been taking place
congressman Jamie Raskin is a Democrat
from Maryland who serves on the House
Judiciary Committee but if it makes
sense to you the people at the IRA the
internet research agency in st.
Petersburg Russia would figure out to go
after black votes in Wisconsin and
Pennsylvania well we don't know whether
or not it was just a coincidence so we
know from the Muller report that there
was a sweeping and systematic campaign
by the Russians to undermine and subvert
our presidential election in order to
throw it Donald Trump and now we have
reported that the Russians were
deliberately trying to suppress African
American women from turning out in
Pennsylvania in Wisconsin and other
places and it looks like that strategy
was parallel to a Republican strategy
and joining us now from Washington to
talk about all this is Jill wine banks a
former member of the Watergate special
prosecutors team and a former executive
director of the American Bar Association
thank you for being here let me ask you
Jill wine banks do you believe in
coincidences
I'm not believer in coincidences or
conspiracy theories of course it's
certainly obvious that the voters who
needed to be suppressed were African
American women but it is not a
coincidence that that's the exact
information and polling data that
Manafort turned over to the Russians and
probably for financial gain he was using
his knowledge to try to get out of some
debts to oligarchs in Russia well do you
think Robert Moeller did enough to
investigate this aspect it seems to have
these these parallel political campaigns
one from st. Petersburg Russia one from
the Trump campaign I think he
established the Russian hacking and the
social media segment but he did not
follow the money which you know going
back to Watergate following the money is
exactly the way to find things and in
this case there's a lot of financial
motives for the cooperation with Russia
Donald Trump wanted to make millions
hundreds of made from the back
out and so he and the same thing is true
for Manfred who owed a great debt in
Russia and he used this power that he
had knowledge that he had to try to win
over some of the oligarchs to relieve
his debt Jill we have a question for you
from the control room from our executive
producer Ron Jill you're a former
prosecutor why couldn't Muller do more
on this why was it beyond his purview
with all our intelligence agencies
couldn't they investigate further
pointment announcement and that said
that he was to investigate whether or
not the russians had hacked and
interfered in our election in any way
and whether anyone the Trump team was
involved in that action which is not the
same thing as whether or not they had
shared polling data I guess I think it's
a logical extension and that if I were
making the decision as robert muller as
to whether or not i had jurisdiction I
would have erred on the side of
inclusiveness and I would have probably
investigated further now there is
clearly future cases still pending and
so the question is whether this is one
of the ones that he did not resolve but
he did not close and that it's one of
the ones he can't talk about because
it's still pending
so you think more might be coming very
quickly Jill I don't know if it'd be
quick but I think there's more coming
for sure Jill Juan banks thank you so
much for being our program tonight very
much appreciate it
coming up Bryan you bet coming up next
is America on the verge of going to war
with Iran in fact is a secret cyber war
already underway when we return
in a summer of shark sightings racist
tweets from the White House and children
held in cages along the southern border
we may have lost sight of the distinct
possibility we could end up at war with
Iran some suggest were already engaged
in a tit-for-tat cyber war Iran has
seized a British ship claims it
disrupted a CIA spy network and acted in
what the US says is a deliberately
provocative manner in the strategic
shipping lanes of the gulf of Hormuz and
while President Trump has not authorized
any military action
he has disclosed the US has conducted
cyber attacks on Iran and issued a stern
warning we'll see what happens with Iran
Iran has to be very very careful joining
us now to talk about all this is Karen
Greenberg the executive director of the
Center for national security at the
Fordham Law School and by Skype from
Cambridge Massachusetts Matt Bonn a
professor at Harvard one of the world's
great experts on nuclear proliferation
and terrorism thank you both for being
here Matt but let me start with you do
you think we're on the brink of
something I think it's very dangerous
right now we have a situation in the
fairly crowded Strait of Hormuz with
lots of different military forces
operating not only there but in Iraq in
Yemen in Syria there are lots of things
that could clash inadvertently and be
the spark for the beginning of a war
meanwhile there is strong tensions
because of the sanctions that the United
States has imposed after pulling out of
the Iran nuclear deal so there's and
there's no negotiations underway to
resolve the situation so that the
situation is really fraught with danger
at the moment I think and you feel one
false step could lead to something quite
disastrous indeed we've seen situations
before where things happened that none
either a commander actually wanted to
happen in 1988
us ship shot down a Iranian civilian
airplane killing everyone aboard and
during the Cuban Missile Crisis there
were all sorts of events that almost led
to war that neither Khrushchev nor
Kennedy ordered to happen so there's
just like there's a fog of war there's a
fog of crisis that can lead to events
that nobody wanted to have happen let me
ask you there's been talk of a cyber war
already underway with attacks from both
sides at each other yeah it's almost
like a parallel conversation that's
going on in the conflict between the
United States and Iran and what you're
seeing is parallel to the Caesar ships
the shooting down of drones that we've
seen what you've seen is a parallel war
going on lots of it we know we don't
hear about what we've heard about some
of it which has to do with us attacking
Iranian intelligence networks and
Iranians targeting our financial and
other networks and some of it's theft
some of it's ransomware and some of its
just to show that they can do it but it
is more getting more and more intense
it's been going on over the course of
the last couple of months and it has not
helped by the fact that the bellicose
language from the president makes it so
that he's pushing Iran further and
further you know first he he withdraws
from the jcpoa then he declares the IRGC
a terrorist organization it's a and then
we begin to retaliate both in terms of
activity and in terms of rhetoric so I
agree with Matt we are in an extremely
dangerous situation without a real sense
of who would be in command to say this
is what should happen either in the
cyber space or in the kinetic space so
far no shots fired but president Trump
has acknowledged a cyber attack no
absolutely and and no shots have been
fired but leading national security
experts often say that the next war the
next hot war we see will be introduced
by a cyber war and so how you make that
distinction what the moment becomes
where it becomes kinetic and and violent
and causes death is a matter of time
Mette but do you think that this cyber
war could lead to a shot being fired
absolutely and arguably their shots
being fired already in the sense that
there were these mines that damaged
several tank tankers that were
attributed to the Iranians
there was the shoot-down of the American
drone President Trump launched a
military strike on Iran which he called
off at the very last moment so I I think
we're closer than many Americans realize
to the brink there are senior people in
the administration who believe that it
would be a good thing to have military
strikes against Iran to take out parts
of their nuclear program I personally
think that would be a disastrous
potentially catastrophic move because we
could set their nuclear program back but
only for a few years and they would
likely rebuild in secret and there are
many things throughout the Middle East
that they could do in response there's a
real danger of setting the whole Middle
East even more on fire than it already
is and Karen in a war like that huge
casualties listen people have been
starting to talk about the difference
between the war with Iraq and what a war
with Iran would be and estimates of
people who live through the Iraq war in
positions of command and official
Authority have said almost to a person
that the Iran war would dwarf what the
Iraq war looked like and and again the
allegations of they're tied to the
greatest terrorist organizations in the
world
are just not true and the amount of
impact that Iran has been able to have
in Syria in Yemen and elsewhere has been
much less than the rhetoric surrounding
it and so I do think we are in a
dangerous situation and I think it and
there's also as Matt pointed out in the
beginning not a minor point the lack of
diplomacy that is that is has any kind
of space now I think you might have seen
that foreign minister Zarif has offered
to talk to the members of Congress
that's interesting because there's a
hunger for diplomacy it has to happen
and right now there are no avenues for
it here
Greenberg from the national security
center at foreign law thank you very
much Matt Bunn and Harvard thank you
very much for joining us tonight when we
come back our shout out for the reporter
in South Carolina who took on one of the
state's most powerful groups it's 46
County Sherriff's now a number of them
could end up behind bars and are shut
out tonight for an investigative
reporter in South Carolina who took on
one of the state's most powerful groups
it's 46 County sheriff's as in most
states it's an elective office and the
local sheriff's in South Carolina rarely
get much attention it was a tip to a
local investigative reporter that led
this summer to prison time for powerful
South Carolina prosecutor Dan Johnson
reporter Tony bartoleme of the Post and
Courier in Charleston South Carolina
found the evidence he needed for his
story on the prosecutor in Johnson's own
expense reports nobody looked at him yet
nobody had sifted through them so I got
a hold of them and started looking
through them and a bunch of things just
immediately about including a $173
override in Minneapolis where bartoleme
used to live I thought you know I bet he
went to Prince's house on the Publix
nine and lo and behold that's exactly
what he did and during that trip he also
too spent money on a major league
baseball game the twins and from there
we started looking into other things
like trips to the Galapagos Islands
there's class plane trips to all over
the country and things like that
bartoleme who is the senior reporter on
the postern couriers investigative team
says they decided to expand their probe
into all official expense reports so we
thought what are other islands of
government in South Carolina that exist
on their own without much scrutiny and
sheriff's immediately came to mind and
as we basically we saw
every spending record we could get from
every county in the state all 46
counties suspended Greenville County
sheriff will Lewis is facing more
charges tonight
among those highlighted by Barlow me was
sheriff will Lewis of Greenville County
now facing criminal charges that he was
using public money to carry on a sexual
relationship with an employee who has
now claimed she was raped he has denied
the charges and her claims her
allegations that basically forced her to
have sex forced her to do other things
in and used that fear of termination
losing her job as a as a cudgel next
with the sheriff of Florence County
people who live in the area are speaking
out after the man they elected sheriff
Kenny Boone was arrested and charged
with embezzlement and misconduct in
office Sheriff Kenny Boone is also now
facing state charges as a result of bar
lemis reporting he too has pleaded not
guilty again it was all these these
these sort of questionable expenses for
personal gain the most serious charges
came following Bartleby's story on
sheriff alex Underwood Underwood had a
pattern of misbehavior ranging from
assaults he'd assaulted a couple of fire
chiefs at a traffic stop and also a man
was live-streaming traffic wreck as the
man was streaming his video on Facebook
sheriff Underwood is seen approaching
him and can be heard challenging him
there was a scuffle essentially
Underwood and his deputies threw the guy
in jail cooked up a bunch of bogus
charges and then tried to cover up when
they FBI began investigate sheriff
Underwood is now under federal
indictment he has pleaded not guilty to
the charges when we put it all together
we produced you know a very large
package of stories that really kinda
captured the scope and
significance of and history of why
sheriff's have gotten into trouble
Bartleby says his editors no such
investigative reporting takes time and
money but that they have decided it is
the only way local newspapers can
survive in the past few years we've
analyzed the data and we've found that
people are more likely to subscribe to
stories that are done with depth and
quality we found that the sheriff story
for instance generated the most
subscriptions of any story last year or
earlier this year on a local level it's
really the only way we'll be able to
survive and we are finding that
investigative journalism though it's
expensive is what keeps people reading
so our shout out tonight for Tony Marla
me and his editors demonstrating how
investigative reporting can do good and
do well on a personal note Tony's father
Joe was one of broadcast journalism is
great and I was fortunate enough to have
worked for him when I first started my
career at NBC News
nice to see Tony's carry on the
tradition of journalism with an impact
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week